يتحمل القطاع الصحي في مارب ضغط يصل الى
10 اضعاف طاقته الاستيعابيه رغم ذلك بقي
صامدا يقدم خدماته الاسعافيه والعلاجيه
ويواجه الامراض الوبائيه والموسميه
والمنتشره هذه الوحده الصحيه في حي المطار
وسط المدينه تضيق بالمرضى الذين لا يجدون
اسره للعلاج او حتى كراسي الانتظار في ظل
انتشار كبير لجائحه حمى الضنك الموسميه
على المركز عدد الحالات اليوميه يتجاوز اا
120 حاله ياتون ليس من الزمام السكاني فقط
بل من المخيمات البعيده مثل المخيم
الجوفينه
هو من الوادي
هذه الايام اكثر الحالات
مثلا حمى الضنك باليوم ما يقارب 40 الى 50
حاله
العدد الزايد في المركز بحاجه الى توسعه
المبنى
بحاجه الى زياده عدد الموظفين اعتماد
الميزانيه عامه للمركز التشغيليه وما شابه
ذلك في 293 مخيما بمدينه مارب ومحيطها
تفتكروا حمى الضنكين فيما تدخلات
والمنظمات الدوليه والمراكز الصحيه على
قلتها في المخيمات لا تقدموا خدمات علاجيه
كافيه لمسانده القطاع الصحي والطواقي
الطبيه ومنها بعده اجراءات من ضمن حملتين
رش ضبابي نطلب من الاخوها المواطنين
التعاون معنا بذلك في ردم همم المستنقعات
والحفاظ على على المياه الراكده بالاضافه
الى ان نطلب من السلطه المحليه التعاون
معنا ايضا
المنظمات المجتمع المدني وايضا المنظمات
الدوليه المتاخره في مارب بحمل ترش ومدنا
بالادويه ومدنا الناموسيات عمليات ورش
المبيدات والت
عقيرها من الاجراءات لم تمنع حمى الضنك من
الانتشار خصوصا في المخيمات القريبه من
قنوات مياه الري
تتزايد حالات الحميات وحمى الضنك في
محافظه مارب في مرمى في كثير من المخيمات
لا يحصلون على الرعايه الصحيه محمود
الحميدي لقناه العربيه مارب